trago aqui um tema pra mim é muito
interessante e em sistema artístico
angolano crise e perspectiva em ter
várias linhas de pesquisa que eu tenho e
é um interesse interesse muito estético
mesmo em relação a este tema
o país está em crise todos nós sabemos
que o país está em crise mas já há
várias formas e fazendo pensar e as
cabeças há várias formas de criar um
recurso criar em forma de um de poderá
sair dinheiro e eu acho que a ata pode
dar se pode sair muito dinheiro a um
sistema pista e com o princípio de forma
básica
mas quando falamos do sistema que
estivemos a existência de 13
instituições funcionais
a primeira e só amanhã é de uma forma
geral sábado é assim só acadêmica para
que falemos numa luta determinado
território do sistema artístico
precisamos ter uma acinte suas acadêmica
as crianças vão à escola primária
aprendendo a fazer a a agricultura ou
pintar e pedagoga está muito bem que a
criança aprende mais com é na atividade
extraveicular entre os quais a arte é
muito importante e não se no meio tempo
só acho que de fato tem que dominar os
conceitos básicos na arte e na prática e
na teoria e pôs termo à universidade ou
estudos superiores onde só as já
praticam o mesmo
mostra uma certa habilidade que é sitava
essa é a primeira instituição só
acadêmica seguindo vem é tem que existir
a distinção os profissionais para que o
sistema artístico seja funcional
os artistas o o osasco é um artista deve
ter no seu ateliê susto de ontem
trabalho deve pautar sempre a
deontologia nos comportado uma outra
forma de vela algumas instituições
diga não fundação gemas é de leão leão
autónomas com fundo autonomy mais
investindo é para que haja a profissão
por outro lado as ações onde está por
exemplo que estão fora da administração
adam a tabela o universitária podem
criar as suas ações
existe uma famosa associação da arte
negra de tv em que trabalhou muito muito
mesmo na record não só das nossas
esculturas máscaras só quero um xodó do
mundo mas também tem ajudado nas
publicações na universidade ucla nos
estados unidos em relação às artes
plásticas
espero que o medo de uma formação geral
e no fim e precisamos que haja a
instituição é promocional no estado até
esta obrigação como estado exercer o
promotor das atas é poder fazer essa
promoção através de bolsa de criação
através de concurso
além do estado tem temos ensa arte por
exemplo tem um bye ato que faz um bom
trabalho também é essas pessoas quando
elas existem e trabalho de forma
autónoma o sistema artístico trilhas e o
sistema artístico no povo é estar fora
um dos desideratos do estado para a
criação de instabilidade econômica
ora é no 3º simpósio sobre a cultura
nacional
no seu discurso de abertura o chefe de
estado prometeu foi em 2006 de 2006
aproveitando o museu da arte
contemporânea prometeu faculdade de
belas artes
eu não tenho tantas coisas mais
estranhas sujeito hoje em dia temos
dentro dessas promessas temos exato que
eu estou superior para almoçar da
criação do dos fazedores da arte é criou
criou o sus em arte depois da do do bebê
da música deixar de existir prontas
criar as duas instituições para que a
que tenha alguma aceitação essa pontuou
o ponto é que a forma como a nossas
instituições quer acadêmica promocionais
e promocional existem a cola não
funciona não funciona a mente por uma
razão muito simples estão numa fase
embrionária da uta tentar ganhar uma
certa autonomia é que na no álbum cab na
linha aí para fazer funcionar para ser
funcional e por isso não funciona mas
não significa que o país tem para o país
continua
é essa organização e muitos e é muito
importante porque na minha pesquisa
sobre eu tenho uma tese que é que falta
um diálogo estético nas minhas viagens
no interior do país para perceber como
funciona o sistema artístico da forma
que é produzido localmente
eu preciso que ela juntava isso com o
sistema econômico mas sair vou tentar
explicar muito rapidamente num sistema
econômico mundo tradicional como
funciona
só as palavras que você estava se
conhecem em que o mundo quando se diz
que é no bairro que viver é aquele que
organiza a produção é não fazer organiza
a produção depois de ver que matar muita
gente tem esse novo na minha irmã eu
tenho estudado isso a marca de uma casa
em vantagem que me maré com o que levará
a que cultiva o clima tá agindo como
agricultor há pessoas que têm uma
especial é um território um e ela não
vai falar com sobre nenhum e vai
contratar sobre nenhum paga sobre o
sérgio à cut do trabalhador da terra
depois de o dedo que makas enquanto
produzem a dos produtos é preciso que
pessoas que vêm de fora a compra só um
sansung e debocha vai aquele que consome
o que é que a gente fica no jardim
embuias científica vem aquele que é
errado dizer 'vou tem espaço no tem esse
poder todo para organizar o trabalho e
ele sobrevive no trabalho dele e que
ganha do só de sombra do seu trabalho
nas artes a mesma coisa em um sistema
bem organizado é que o produto final e
enriquece o o o cria uma estabilidade
econômica no topo
isso é muito importante para o as artes
plásticas como podemos por exemplo
diversificar a economia através das
artes e taboão está fazendo para melhor
foi promover e criar leis que ela
dizendo presente em todas as sessões
públicas deve ter seu patrimônio
cultural deve ter x obra de si sós nas
artes plásticas principalmente onde até
mesmo de 300 profissionais se estado
criar essa criança com essa
possibilidade vamos lá ver um míssil da
inadequação exterior
decorar todos os edifícios que estão no
a volta do nosso país e de coragem
as representações vão ver que os
artistas plástico não só voltei emprego
não só vão ter emprego não voltavam ter
é vou criar uma estabilidade social nas
suas famílias
a criação de um estado na sala passar
quando um cidadão não só contribuiu não
só me civil mas passa a ser um um
suporte fundamental no reconhecimento do
local não se encontra
e quando nós trabalhamos das artes
plástica
podemos ver que as ats vai contribuir
não só para a criação da estabilidade
nas pessoas que fazem mas o estado
também ganha com isso
para ganhar é preciso gaza essa
estrutura
um fã do bicho há pouco tempo hoje hoje
as pessoas aqui bolinou sãmbolo usual
mundo o mundo ela por si só tem uma
estrutura econômica que funciona de fato
não precisa morrer buscar aqui e acolá é
nos temos protótipos que podem ser até
eu agradeço às pessoas que me veio antes
de mim um arquiteto que acho que foi
nada basta vendas de algumas discussões
que tenhamos que tivemos no passado quem
não via necessidade de adaptar à
habitação dos ao ano consoante a sua
cultura cultura é impossível a escultura
portugal deve deixar de existir numa sol
por exemplo tá ao falar com voz que eu
tenho que traduzir numa língua que minha
materna falar a língua portuguesa
portuguesa não francesa depois português
é um exercício que woods mim próprio eu
faço para falar a língua portuguesa isso
faz parte da estrutura onde eu nasci
onde cresci o estado criar é exibições
acadêmicas criança na escola primária
vai ter gosto para ato ele terá que
visitar os museus e vão perceber que a
atleta vai perceber outras dimensões
carta oferece aluno desenvolvimento do
indivíduo ou seja a integridade
ontológica de uma criança para o
instrumento é e nem primeira infância
até a universidade sim pautamos galatto
não só estava ganha criando ato é um
único espaço onde seguir a moda
há um único espaço onde seguia longa
há muita gente falou do diálogo até
mesmo espaço para o diálogo era para
quem faz música que é pra nós vimos aqui
comigo né
quando diz cômico tô velho a comédia no
sentido grego
a média é a tragicomédia foi fundamental
na criação do espírito do cidadão da
grécia ea ata o quando fora aproveitado
pelo estado não só ganha com a criação
do cidadão é criar nenhum cidadão que
vai ser próspero prola por outro lado
quando fomenta a atriz que já fazem e
que a estabilidade nas solas nossa
companhia e 121o a sua fundação vem
fazendo pela publicidade a fundação
sindika dokolo o trouxe algumas mágoas
máscara para o país
pouca gente percebeu subir não sei
quantos quantos e quantos com deram que
foi pago mas é interessante não só
quando os as autoridades absurdas viram
aquilo sentiram-se identificado
o investimento das ats
se está bom e investir na ato que cria
as instituiçons de forma a que mesmo
ganhar a sua autonomia
só poderemos perceber por que é que isso
tem sentido uma criança que desde a
eternidade aprendi a valorizar isso
ainda que esteja ainda que veja é esse
documento em que se não estiverem faz
sentir identificado
eu fui nomeado em 2000 e 2008 como e
méxico ao visitar na na na onu num lugar
e do outro lado tocava batuque
não vou tocar button que eu deixei onde
estava porque eu me identificava com
button e eu fui de fato velho
o batuque significa dizer ainda que eu
tenha esse fosse um milionário que uma
hora vez que veio num sítio qualquer
eu pego o dinheiro um fato tabu para mim
tem que dar voltar aí a importância de
vestir logo a ter a idade para criança
formar se nas artes
essa máscara é chamado um bombeiro a
palavra um batom mais utilizou muito
importante
muitas vezes nossa crise para ser
ultrapassada é preciso encontrar
soluções
internamente o foi negro longa no umbará
guerrón que encontra uma explicação
dessa crença dessa por essa escultura o
também não sabia o que significa um
samba e foram explicados da seguinte
forma nos para criar uma nova
estabilidade econômica
optámos pela arte é que há um elemento
de identificação mas deixa de estar
ligado com a sua ata é essa é mágica
só que nessa máscara é quem conhece
muito bem a morfologia vão perceber que
há um ano há pouco a isso só de monapo
não explica a importância pessoas
conhecer as suas gorduras mas fica
também o pessoal lá é obedecer e as
instituições e criar as outra mais para
que haja uns papa para que haja um
espaço comum para todos
o que é especial essa máscara que cor
muda quando você foi uma mulher mas com
é corrupta conforme chamado porque é
importante essa máscara eu vi isso vive
a trabalhar com vittek essa obra não sei
quem tem essa obra eu já publiquei um
livro com essa coisa alguma
com esta obra que fez o convite pouca
gente por dentro da nossa sociedade
conheça kiev tente deter se conhecia
legia o nosso só uma escrita na idéia
nem se conhecia nossa aaa a gramática
das cores e transportou isso um para sua
arte
só que o que acontece o que ele fez
ficou só com ele foi do outro lado é a
estética ficou com ela e agora diante
não temos como levar isso para a
juventude prata reproduzir a nossa é
cultura nessa nessa área
essa é uma obra de antónio aula já na
hora da onu para perceber sua arte é
preciso perceber é antônio aula
agora o que quero apresentar antônio
lançou trata de luanda hoballah
populações vieram da preferia até dois
mato o para guarda e à cultura foi foi
criada uma cultura que existem guarda
uma cultura que identifica todos ao
mesmo tempo sou alto ao sul da antônio
aula através dessa pintura de e outros
como saber outros nos percebendo uma
coisa muito importante que isso que o
senhor presidente perceba
só que acontecessem termos as sessões
acadêmicas
essa obra nunca será levada na
universidade para estudar e quando
antónio rola amanhã já não existirá
pintura de nunca ter visto nenhum valor
o estado pelo lado cometeu é de não
valorizar o cidadão e o nojo este é o
preocupante tanto da arte não vão
conseguir beneficiar não só do bem estar
social que deve ver nem sequer é a sua
os futuros que virão fazer até vão do
fato um raro os seus homens
a minha coligação para terminar eu disse
a ser tolo é resume no seguinte o chefe
de estado em 2006 lançou a idéia de
criado algumas sessões para aquele
estado haja o sistema artístico mas há
um sistema artístico de funcionar com a
organização não precisamos buscar uma
orientação de fora não saibam como
funciona o sistema artístico londres
está chovendo saibam como funciona
agora a minha proposta é ao criar um
sistema artístico angolano tem deverá
primeiro para primeiro branco a brisa
queria e rentabilizar os capitais
culturais que cada um tem que fazer a
cada um tem e permitir que o que este
vem já estará a fazer permaneça para que
o futuro volta a utilizar isso assim
como criar um sistema consistente
muito obrigado